well getting an acceptance letter from
your top college is a really truly a
special moment now we all know you gotta
have everything lined up just right
right but the pandemic did change the
way universities conduct their business
what they're looking for in a student
though one expert tells us don't expect
the change to remain permanent
mia gupta is the ceo of college
shortcuts the business helps students as
early as eighth grade learn to build
their portfolio and resume we help
students with their essays understanding
which schools to pick that are right fit
for them and then we increased the
probability of students getting accepted
into those competitive top schools and
while high scores on exams like the act
and sat have long been key indicators on
acceptance into a certain university
niha says 71 percent of universities
went test optional during the pandemic
this course of action created some
unique opportunities we saw a lot of
students from last year that may not
have had the academic standing fully to
get into those schools with the perfect
gpa the perfect sat score they're
getting in niha says school admissions
officers at top universities are looking
at the human aspect putting a lot more
weight on essays as opposed to testing
scores as a major driver for why that
student should be accepted they're
looking for the students that aren't
just going to sit in their dorm they're
looking for the students that are going
to be activists community leaders doing
something with their degree but don't
expect the trend to be permanent as more
testing sites open up niha says testing
will once again become a big decision
factor in who gets accepted